the fbi in denver announcing autopsy
results confirming that the body found
in wyoming is indeed has been identified
as gabby petito for more on that let's
go to laurie engel outside the coroner's
office in jackson wyoming laura
well good afternoon we have been here
all day awaiting word knowing that
today's autopsy was taking place there
was a flurry of activity a short while
ago we weren't sure what that was and as
you just mentioned the fbi uh tweeting
out the results uh the coming from the
teton county coroner dr brent blue
confirming the remains that were
discovered here in wyoming on sunday are
those of gabrielle petito they gave out
her birth date of march 19 1999 in
confirmation the coroner's initial
determination for the manner of death is
homicide along with this announcement
the fbi in denver also put out a tweet
with an additional statement that i will
read to you saying the fbi's commitment
to justice is at the forefront of each
and every investigation said fbi denver
special agent in charge michael
schneider the fbi and our partners
remain dedicated to ensuring everyone
anyone responsible for or complicit and
miss petito's death is held accountable
for their actions and mr brian laundry
has been named a person of interest
anyone with information concerning mr
laundry's role in this matter or his
current whereabouts should contact the
fbi important to note he is still being
considered a person of interest even at
this point i just spoke to the family
attorney in new york representing all
the parents involved here for
gabrielle potido and they said that they
could confirm that the family knows that
the identification has been made they
told us earlier today that once gabby is
brought home that is when the family
will issue a statement in person we are
expecting a press conference at some
point from them when she has returned
home greg
thanks laura hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else